so i'm sure a lot of people have been  wondering about the world championship  recently  as many know i was in madrid for the  conclusion of  the  the candidates tournament  um  after the conclusion uh i did agree to  meet with um  um  with uh dwarkovich and uh satovsky from  from fida to  um to talk a little bit  uh i did not  have any demands or suggestions for that  meeting um  they did have  a couple of suggestions  [Music]  but  the gist of it was  that i was there to tell them that  i would not defend my title  in  in the next world championship match  um  and we had a small discussion they had  some suggestions  some of them i liked some of them i did  did not but ultimately  the  conclusion stands  one that i'm pretty comfortable with  one that i thought  a lot about  um  for a long time now i would say  more more than a year probably  a year and a half almost since long  before the last  match  um